I wonder what people from Korea and
Japan think when they come to the UK
like look at me coming from one of the
hilarious most binge drinking cultures
on the planet doing these Asian people
are drinking a lot dude I did a seminar
in Sunderland but I was staying in
Newcastle literally on that street that
you used to work on I have never seen
nightlife like that it was the loudest
and dude it was people of all ages there
were like 40 year olds getting oh my God
they were getting faced that was binge
drinking like I have never really seen
it's almost treated like a competitive
sport I feel like the people in
Newcastle are like oh it's Friday
let's black out this was one of the big
changes that I had when I did sobriety I
went from having a Friday afternoon itch
which was this compulsion this desire to
party like I just wanted to go out and
get up even if it wasn't get
up I just wanted to go out even
if you take it moderately a moderate
session in the UK it's still gonna be
eight drinks it's like when you know
that you want a coffee but for a beer